Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Die 2 Sprechstunden.
Morgen bring ich sie um. Morgen bring ich sie um. Wenn ihr euch fragt, wovon ich rede, ich rede von Leuten, die hier vom Chaos Computer Club im Chaos Radio zu Gast sind. Auf den Namen Erdgeist, Nibbler und Linus hören. Hallo Gunther nochmal. Und die heute mal erklären wollen Ansätze. Also wir machen heute hier Cryptoparty. Entsprechend geht es hier auch zu. Aber es gibt auch etwas Sinnvolles dabei zu lernen, nämlich die Anfänge von Verschlüsselung. Wir haben schon grob erklärt, wie Verschlüsselung überhaupt funktioniert. Und haben jetzt so die Verschlüsselung, die man seinen Eltern mal installieren kann. Also Dinge, die das Computerleben sicherer machen, aber die trotzdem, wenn sie erst mal da sind, so einfach zu benutzen sind, dass sie niemanden mehr verwirren. Und jetzt hatte gerade noch jemand angerufen, der eine Frage zur Festplattenverschlüsselung hatte und der jetzt in dem Moment, wo ich ihn drannehmen wollte, aufgelegt hat.
So macht das natürlich keinen Sinn.
Ihr könnt immer sozusagen, das ist nämlich das Angebot in der Sendung, auch anrufen, wenn ihr eine Verständnisfrage habt oder etwas noch besser erklären könnt als die drei Gäste, die hier in der Sendung sitzen und das erklären wollen. Ich glaube, wir kriegen den Carlo, der da angerufen hatte, gleich nochmal rein. Und genau da ist er. Hallo Carlo.
Ja, hallo.
Du hattest noch eine Frage zur Festplattenverschlüsselung, die wir ja gerade erklärt haben.
Genau, aber im Webstream wurden schon einige Sachen beantwortet. Ja, aber da war jetzt so die Frage Bitlocker oder TrueCrypt oder verschlüssel ich jetzt meinen USB-Stick, den ich verlieren kann, mit TrueCrypt oder ist das jetzt, sag ich mal, für Freunde, Familie zu kompliziert oder wie bringt man denen das vernünftig bei?
Ausprobieren.
Also du hörst dich schlau genug an, als ob du das einfach mal installieren kannst. Und wenn es dir zu schwer fällt, dann ist es wahrscheinlich für deine Eltern auch nichts. Aber du konntest ja schon so grob das Gefühl dafür entwickeln, wo die Fallstricke sind, die du selber beim Installieren hast und danach kannst du empfehlen. Also ich hab da sehr gute Erfahrungen mitgemacht und es ist inzwischen einfach klicken und vergessen. Geht einfach.
Okay, gut. Und wie kann man den Leuten das mal beibringen, wenn die jetzt ihren neuen USB-Stick kaufen, dass sie den dann auch wirklich verschlüsseln? Also da ist ja auch immer viel V-Herrheit dabei, ja?
Puh, man muss doch halt USB-Sticks kaufen, die gleich Verschlüsselung mit eingebaut haben. Da gibt's ja welche, wo du den Fingerabdruck drüberfahren musst.
Also was da Carlo vielleicht nicht weiß, ist, dass der Chaos Computer Club auch der Club ist, der mal Fingerabdrücke zum Nachbau eine Anleitung dafür gestellt hat. Also die Frage nochmal, die Hände verblüht ist...
Ich hab diese Sendung über Fingerabdrücke gehört, ja.
Nicht mal die Hörer lassen mich hier noch reden. Also die Frage, die sich dahinter versteckt, ist ja sozusagen, dieses TrueCrypt ist auch anwendbar auf USB-Sticks? Kann man die dann auch an Rechnern betreiben, auf denen kein TrueCrypt installiert ist?
Du meinst, man kann sie auf Rechnern betreiben, wo noch kein TrueCrypt installiert ist?
Kann man die auf Rechnern betreiben?
Ja, wenn da mehrere Partitionen drauf sind, dann kann man auch diese USB-Sticks auf... Na, Partitionen ist ja die Art und Weise, wie man Festplatten in mehrere kleine virtuelle Festplatten unterteilt. Und man muss nicht alle Partitionen auf seinem USB-Stick, wenn man da mehrere Partitionen eingerichtet hat, kann man eine verschlüsseln.
Das heißt, man kann den USB-Stick aufteilen, dass man einen verschlüsselten Teil hat und einen unverschlüsselten Teil...
Okay, aber den unverschlüsselten Teil kommt man nicht ran, wenn der Rechner noch keinen TrueCrypt installiert hat.
Doch, an den unverschlüsselten Teil kommt man ran.
Man macht es sich doch noch einfacher. Man legt einfach auf den unverschlüsselten Teil dieses USB-Sticks...
TrueCrypt.
TrueCrypt. Und da liegt einfach die Binary drauf, die ich brauche, um das wieder zu entschlüsseln. Preferabel direkt für die gängigen Betriebssysteme kompiliert und alles ist gut. Oder der Installer, damit man halt auch mal auf seinem Weg über die anderen Computer auch Spuren hinterlässt und den Menschen Gutes tut. Also eine Art Verschlüsselungsleiter.
Also pack ich...
Darf ich nochmal? Also nehme ich meinen USB-Stick, pack da einen TrueCrypt-Container drauf und tu da einen Mac-Installer drauf und einen Windows-Installer und dann kommt man damit gut zurecht.
Genau, dann tust du da in den verschlüsselten Teil was rein, was deine Eltern unbedingt wollen und sagst dann klar, ihr müsst euch nur diese Entschlüsselungssoftware installieren.
So und ich hab die Sendung nicht von ganz Anfang gehört. Ihr habt ein bisschen so über E-Mail-Verschlüsselgeräte. Habt ihr schon über Pretty Good Privacy-Geräte?
So ein bisschen, aber es kommt eigentlich noch. Ja, es kommt noch. So Theorie dahinter so ein bisschen, aber so richtig, kommen wir noch.
Ja, okay, weil das hab ich auch nie geschafft, bei irgendwelchen Leuten zu etablieren.
Möglicherweise scheitern auch wir heute dran, aber wir werden noch mal einen Versuch starten. Carlo, vielen Dank erst mal. Und viel Spaß noch. Und dann haben wir noch den Mo. Hallo Mo.
Grüße.
Auch noch eine Frage zur Verschlüsselung.
Na ja, eine Frage und eine Anmerkung. Und zwar habt ihr meiner Meinung nach bis jetzt diesen ganzen Hardware-Spaß vergessen. Und zwar gibt es da von SSDs den schönen Cent-Force-Controller. Der hat einfach AES eingebaut. Und Hitachi nennt seinen ganzen Spaß BTE Bulk Disk Encryption. Und bei Western Digital Platten nennt die das Full-Disk Encryption. Die sind angeblich auch im Militär von der USA zugelassen. Mit einer FIPS-140-Tätigierung.
Du redest gerade über Sachen, die niemand mehr versteht. Die niemand mehr versteht, außer die Leute, die im Studio sitzen, die eh schon wissen, wovon du redest.
Aber bei denen hat er auch angerufen.
Leute, der Punkt ist, es gibt also Festplatten, die Hardware-Verschlüsselung.
Also das ist sozusagen eine Verschlüsselungsfunktion in der Festplatte eingebaut. Das ist dann nicht eine Software, die auf deinem Computer läuft, sondern die Festplatte verschlüsselt selbst.
Und wann fragt die mich nach dem Passwort?
Irgendwie muss der Schlüssel da auch noch mal wieder hin.
Na ja, der Schlüssel von den Kisten ist in den ersten, ich sag mal jetzt, Segmenten oder ersten Clustern der Festplatte mit drinne, der wiederum verschlüsselt ist und dann über dieses IDA Security abgefragt wird.
Das heißt, ich hab keine Ahnung mehr. Beim Einschalten will der Computer von dir ein Passwort haben. Und mit wem wird der Schlüssel entschlüsselt, mit dem dann die Festplatte verschlüsselt ist, kann man nutzen. Aber das Problem ist, du kannst es halt nicht überprüfen. Also das kann für zertifiziert und alles Mögliche sein, aber du weißt halt nicht, ob dein Schlüssel, den du da eingibst, also dein Passwort das einzige Passwort ist, dass du den Schlüssel verschlüsselt. Das hat man beispielsweise bei Netzwerkfestplatten schon das öfteren gesehen. Da ist die zwar total coole funktionierende Krypto machen, aber wenn man dann reinguckt, dann sieht man, da gibt es fünf Speicherplätze für Passworter. Und standardmäßig, wenn das Gerät kommt, ist schon einer belegt. Wenn man dann einen hinzufügt, dann sind da noch drei frei. Das heißt, es ist ein Passwort schon vergeben, was wohl in der Fabrik da reingewandert ist.
Falls du deins vergisst, muss natürlich auch jemand... Das finde ich schon sehr vorausschauend von der Firma.
Also grundsätzlich kann man sowas gerne verwenden, aber man sollte sich nicht drauf verlassen. Im Zweifel einfach noch mal...
Aber wie sieht das aus, weil kryptomäßig krieg ich das doch gar nicht hin, das mit fünf Passworten zuverschlüsseln.
Na doch, der Trick ist der, dass du da so einen Schlüssel hast. Und...
Du legst nebeneinander einfach fünf verschiedene Versionen, die du jeweils mit einem anderen Schlüssel verschlüsselst. Und wenn es entschlüsselt, kommt dann der wirkliche Schlüssel raus. Das ist üblicherweise die Idee. Aber wir sind gerade dabei, irgendwie eher die niedrig hängenden Früchte zu besprechen und neue Festplatten für die Eltern zu kaufen. Ist halt für die meisten Leute da irgendwie grad nicht drin. Die wollen einfach hin und mal schnell ein wenig was installieren, ein bisschen was klicken. Und die könnten dann später noch mal darauf zurückkommen, wenn wir dann in den Aluhutbereich kommen. Da können wir uns dann die Festplatten, die irgendwie ihre Krypto schon mitbringen, dann noch mal näher angucken.
Ja, also es geht heute vor allem darum, dass man die einfachen Sachen erklärt. Du hattest noch eine Frage?
Na ja, meine Frage war eigentlich schon beantwortet. Es ging ja eigentlich um die, wie ihr die Sicherheit von dem Zeug einschätzt. Weil, wie gesagt, ich hab dann eine schöne Lösung für meinen Fatih umgesetzt, ohne dass der den Schlüssel eingeben muss. Der wird einfach über Linux sozusagen, jedes Mal, wenn er hochfährt, über die Enid RD aus dem Internet geladen, aus zwei verschiedenen Stellen, was wiederum mit PGP verschlüsselt ist und dann dort lokal anschlüsselt wird. Und damit kann ich ja den Schlüssel sozusagen auf die Festplatte legen.
Das zählt definitiv nicht zu den einfachen Lösungen, die wir heute den Leuten erklären können. Aber es ist ein interessanter Ansatz.
Klingt auch so, als wäre das nicht so hundertprozentig.
Vielleicht könntet ihr die Diskussion aufwärmen.
Kommt noch mal in den IRC. Free Note, Routel, Chaos Radio. Können wir uns noch mal kurz drunterhalten? Das würde mich interessieren. Kann man gerne machen.
Wir haben noch einen, den Max aus Baden-Württemberg. Hallo Max.
Hallo, ich hab das mal ausprobiert mit einer Festverschlüsselung. Ich hatte das Problem, dass mein System danach so langsam war, dass ich nichts mehr benutzen konnte. Da wollte ich wissen, wie kann man das machen.
Was hast du da benutzt?
Fedora, da gab es irgendwo so einen Haken, wo Verschlüsselung gesagt wurde. Toll, nehme ich Verschlüsselung. Hab es genommen und dann habe ich festgestellt, es dauert so lange. Ich konnte dem einen Kaffee trinken gehen, bis das System irgendwas gemacht hat, bis es meinen Aufblick ausgeführt hat.
Das ist ja keine Lux.
Was war das für ein System? Was für ein Prozessor?
Der war nicht ganz so schnell, der hat 2x 1, 6 GHz gehabt.
Was für einen Prozessor? Wie hieß dieser Prozessor? Irgendwas, das sind so... Es spielt schon eine Rolle, weil neuere Intel-Generationen die gängigen AES-Crypto-Operationen schon im Prozessor drin haben. Was diesen Rechenaufwand sehr stark verringert. Wenn der Prozessor etwas älter ist und das nicht mitmacht, dann hast du auch wirklich Last auf der CPU, weil du die ganze Zeit am Fair- und Endschlüsseln bist beim Schreiben auf die Festplatte. Und ab dem modernen i5-Prozessor hast du halt das AES Instruction Set im Prozessor drin. Und der macht das halt einfach...
Was? Die Frage war doch...
Da spürst du halt keinen Unterschied.
Was war eigentlich deine Frage, Max? Warum ist es langsam geworden?
Ich hab das mal probiert und ich wollte wissen, warum war das so langsam? Und ihr meint einfach, weil ich den falschen Prozessor hab.
Nicht den falschen, sondern einen, der mit diesen Operationen offensichtlich stark gefordert war.
Ich weiß nicht. Eigentlich ist AIS auch so schon schnell genug, dass wenn sie da nicht irgendwas in der Implementierung falsch gemacht haben, kann ich mir eigentlich heutzutage mit Prozessoren dienen, die jünger als 10 Jahre sind, sollte das keinen... Das geht im Rauschen der Zeit, die man braucht, um die Daten von der Festplatte zu laden, unter. AIS ist eigentlich echt schnell und...
Im Zweifel lag es tatsächlich daran, dass du da NCFS verwendet hast und nicht Lux.
Ich glaub, das ist auch schon wieder ein bisschen zu detailliert jetzt. Also ich kann eigentlich aus eigener Erfahrung auch sagen, dass Festplattenverschlüsselung anzumachen seit, keine Ahnung, das ist die letzten 5 Jahre sein, keinen ernstzunehmenden Impact mehr hat auf dein System. Wenn du dort einfach nur Häkchen anmachst, dann sollte das gehen.
Oh gut, dann probier's halt irgendwann noch aus. Irgendwann krieg ich's hin.
Genau, dann fang ich mit dem halbwegs aktuellen Rechner an. Max, viel Spaß. Das ist übrigens eine ganz wichtige Sache. Klar ist das so ein bisschen nervig. Und klar, wenn man andere Leute davon überzeugen will, dann sollte es einfach so funktionieren. Aber man kann auch einfach mal so ein bisschen rumspielen, ausprobieren. Auch dazu wollen wir heute hier ermutigen. Ich möchte jetzt gerne noch den letzten Punkt bei den Eltern ansprechen. Und das ist, das hat ja mittlerweile jeder so ein Smartphone in der Tasche. Und da ist dann WhatsApp drauf. Und dann rollen alle mit den Augen, weil WhatsApp, oh Gott, das ist doch und so weiter und so fort. Da gibt es ja oder gibt es da auch Möglichkeiten, über Smartphone sicher mit so einem Messenger umzugehen? Also kann ich iMessage nehmen? Kann ich SMS nehmen? Kann ich halt WhatsApp vielleicht doch nehmen?
Na ja, erklären wir vielleicht mal, wo bei WhatsApp das Problem liegt.
WhatsApp hat eine sehr freigiebige Policy, mit deinen Kontakten umzugehen. Das ist auf der einen Seite toll.
Und die andere Seite, das funktioniert erst mal dadurch, dass es überhaupt mal dein komplettes Adressbuch, wenn diesen WhatsApp-Dienst hochlädt, um zu gucken, wer aus deinen Freunden, also die gucken sich deine ganzen Telefonnummern an, die du da hast, um zu gucken, wer von deinen Freunden auch WhatsApp hat.
Das ist natürlich dann total bequem, weil sich dadurch automatisch so ein soziales Netzwerk herausbildet von den Leuten, die da mitspielen, wird dir dann auch gleich vorgeschlagen, mit wem du dann irgendwie noch da schnacken können möchtest. Das Problem dabei ist, dass wenn du nicht selber den Schlüssel austauschst, muss es jemand für dich tun, wenn sie überhaupt verschlüsseln würden, was sie in den ersten Versionen auch überhaupt gar nicht gemacht haben. Und trotzdem bieten sie dir keine Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung an, weil du ja nie mit dem anderen Ende den Schlüssel ausgetauscht hast. Also ein generelles Problem bei Messengern, bei denen du dir über den Austausch des Schlüssels keine Gedanken machst, ist, dass es jemand anders für dich tut, dem du dann generell vertrauen musst. Wenn das ein Vi-Message ist von Apple, heißt das, dass du Apple vertrauen musst, dass der Schlüssel, der dort auf beide Geräte getan wird, wenn es eine Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung ist, wirklich niemand außer dir und deinem Gegenüber und Apple und dem Geheimdienst und vielleicht noch die Mitarbeitern dort erkennt. Und für alles, was du wirklich Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsseln möchtest, musst du dir Gedanken darüber machen, wie der Schlüssel ausgetauscht wird.
Bei WhatsApp wissen auch die Firmen, was es ist. Gibt es da eine Runde von neuen Messenger, die versprechen, das besser zu machen?
Ich würde gerne noch mal vorher, du hast ja SMS noch erwähnt, SMS hat unterwegs mehr als genug Probleme, ging bis vor noch gar nicht allzu ferner Zeit, komplett unverschlüsselt über die Funkschnittstelle. Das heißt, dass ganz normale SMS schon mitgelesen werden konnten bis vor 5 Jahren, wenn du einfach nur einen Rechner aufgeklappt hast, der das GSM-Protokoll konnte. Die Verschlüsselung, die dort standardmäßig an ist, um Sprache zu verschlüsseln, wurde bei vielen Betreibern für SMS gar nicht mit angemacht. Danach hast du das Problem, dass eine SMS, wenn sie dann erstmal beim Betreiber ist, kommt sie dann zum nächsten Betreiber. Auf der anderen Seite wird sie auch genauso unverschlüsselt wieder aufs andere Telefon runtergefunkt und kann dort eigentlich an jeder der Stelle da mitgelesen werden. Also SMS ist schon mal wie noch einen deutlichen Zacken leichter einzusehen als alles, was du dir jetzt obendrauf auf deinem Betriebssystem, wo du dir ein bisschen Crypto ausdenkst.
Okay, jetzt gibt es sozusagen eine Runde neuer Messenger. Für mich zumindest war der Anfang war Threemer, Schweizer Firma, die jetzt so ein Ding rausbringt, wo sie sagen, okay, hier, das ist Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt. Nicht mal wir wissen, was in den Nachrichten drin steht und wir werfen die auch weg, wenn sie ausgeliefert wurden. Dann gibt es jetzt zu sagen, hat der Typ, der bei Pirate Begins viel mitgemacht hat, der Peter Sunde heißt er, der hat jetzt Hemmles angekündigt, Dienst, der so ähnlich funktionieren soll. Dann gibt es noch so Berliner, die jetzt Hocker XO an den Start gebracht haben. Auch so ein Dienst, also auch so ein Smartphone Messenger, der, wo es auch eine schöne, also was heißt ich, schöne, aber immerhin eine Erklärung gibt, welche Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen sie da benutzen. Sind das jetzt alles Dienste, wo man sagen kann, okay, die funktionieren dann oder ist das auch so, naja, hm?
Definiere doch mal funktionieren.
Die versprechen Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung.
Sie, also wenn sie Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung versprechen und den Source Code offenlegen, dann kann man sich das angucken. Dann kann man sagen, ja, sie haben dort einen der Algorithmen benutzt, die im Allgemeinen als sicher achtet werden von der kryptografischen Community und sie haben keine Fehler gemacht dabei den Zufall auszuwürfen, sie haben keine Fehler dabei gemacht, zu überprüfen, ob der Schlüssel, den du mit deinem Gegenüber austauschst, wirklich derselbe ist, auch auf beiden Seiten. Und wenn das alles gegeben ist, was bei Freema zum Beispiel nicht gegeben ist, was auch bei Hemmles nach aktuellem Stand nicht gegeben sein wird.
Weil den gibt's auch noch gar nicht.
Also gerade gibt es von Hemmles nur eine schöne Webseite, die so aussieht wie, keine Ahnung, abgeschleckt. Wo sie wahrscheinlich eher mit dem Namen von Peter Sunde hausieren gehen wollen und mit einem smoothen Interface, um diesen Messenger ins Volk zu bringen. Da würde ich grundsätzlich gar nichts empfehlen. Es ist halt dann immer schon ein bisschen besser als nichts, aber du sollst dich am Ende nicht sicher fühlen deswegen. Du kannst da irgendwie schon noch mehr Rauschen erzeugen, aber dich komplett darauf zu verlassen, dass du da jetzt Staatsgeheimnisse darüber austauschen kannst, wird ich ohne dass der Quellcode offen ist natürlich nicht.
Das ist bei so was wie einem Mobiltelefon eh illusorisch zu glauben, dass man da ja auch noch einen Ansatz von Sicherheit hat.
Ja gut, wir müssen den Hörern aber noch irgendwas mitgeben, was sie vielleicht nehmen können. Also bei diesem Threemer habe ich doch das eigentlich so verstanden, dass sie zumindest in der Software vorgesehen haben, dass du einen direkten Vergleich deiner Schlüssel machst und das dann auch mit so einer Art Trust-Level für den Key dir wiedergeben. Ja, dass sie sagen, wenn du wirklich jetzt mit eigenen Augen...
Lass mal die Hörer nicht im Regen stehen. Also Trust-Level für den Key. Du musst, wenn du... Lass uns mal dieses ganze PKI-Problem jetzt angehen. Schlüssel zu verteilen auf die Endgeräte ist kein leichtes Problem. Es hat ziemlich viel mit Vertrauen zu tun und es gibt Möglichkeiten dafür zu sorgen, dass du mit einer zentralen Instanz, die für dich die Autorität ist, dann einfach bestimmt, der Schlüssel gehört jetzt zu dieser Person. Das ist jetzt so. In größeren Firmen ist es üblicherweise so, dass dort ein Standard namens SMIME benutzt wird, um dafür zu sorgen, dass es eine zentrale Instanz gibt, die für alle Mitarbeiter den Schlüssel verwaltet und die dann auf die Telefone oder Computer oder Endgeräte drauf tut. Und dann ist es einfach so, du musst aber...
Also es geht um das Problem, ich schreibe Erdgeist eine Nachricht, ich nutze einen Schlüssel, um diese Nachricht zu verschlüsseln. Ich möchte aber, ich kann aber nicht wissen, dass dieser Schlüssel jetzt auch derjenige ist, den Erdgeist und nur Erdgeist entschlüsseln kann.
So, das heißt also bei der Firma, die dieses SMIME benutzt, geht quasi mein Rechner zum zentralen Firmserver und fragt so, du, ich will an den Typen Erdgeist aus der Abteilung PR mal irgendwie was schreiben, gib mir mal den Schlüssel. Dann wird der sozusagen ausgeliefert, mein Mailprogramm.
Du musst erstmal nur deiner zentralen Instanz, also du brauchst am Ende nur einen einzigen Schlüssel, nämlich den von der zentralen Instanz, der du vertrauen kannst. Das ist dann nämlich dieser Server, der diese ganzen anderen Schlüssel verwaltet. Und solange ich dort irgendwo einen Ankerpunkt habe, wo ich einen Schlüssel austauschen muss im Vorfeld, nämlich den von meinem zentralen Server, solange bin ich dann sicher in meinem Firmenetzwerk, ich kann dem vertrauen und benutze aber nur für die interne Kommunikation in der Firma diesen Schlüssel.
Aber das ist doch dann bei solchen Sachen wie 3MAR genauso. Da gibt es dann den zentralen Anbieter, also die Firma, die den Messenger auf den Markt bringt. Und dann hol ich mir diesen Zentral, also dann kommuniziere ich da mit meinem vertrauenswürdigen Einstiegspunkt und kriege dann die Schlüssel von dem.
Genau, und jetzt kommt das Problem, dieser Punkt, die könnten ja jetzt dir auch etwas Falsches sagen. Weil du vertraust den ja. Das heißt, du vertraust 3MAR. Und wenn die sich jetzt entscheiden oder ins Ohr geflüstert bekommen, du der Erdgeist, wenn der nächste Mal dem Linus was schreibt, dann gib dem mal einen anderen Schlüssel. Und dann setzen wir uns in der Mitte hin, kriegen die Nachricht, die der Erdgeist schickt, entschlüsseln sie, verschlüsseln sie erneut und dann mit dem Schlüssel, den der Linus lesen kann, und senden sie an ihn.
Vielleicht sollten wir vorher nochmal erklären, warum das so ein Problem ist, solche Schlüssel einfach untereinander auszutauschen. Ich sag dir jetzt mal kurz, am Telefon oder im Real lieben vielen Zahlen, die schreibst du dir auf und das ist mein Schlüssel, so funktioniert das leider nicht. So ein Schlüssel ist üblicherweise echt lang und irgendwie so lang, dass dir beim Abschreiben ganz sicher Fehler passieren werden. Dass du also für den Transfer des Schlüssels schon noch andere elektronische oder optische Möglichkeiten brauchst, wie zum Beispiel ein QR-Code oder irgendwas, wo du effizient einen Schlüssel transportieren kannst, ohne dass es jemand mitliest. Also einen Schlüssel zum Beispiel in einer unverschlüsselten E-Mail im Vorfeld zu schicken. So, hier ist mein privater Key, schick mal bitte was. Funktioniert halt genauso wenig. Jaja, nee. Hier ist mein privater Key, damit wir einen symmetrischen...
Ich muss an der Stelle mal unterbrechen, weil immer Public Key und Private Key...
Nee, halt.
Wir kommen jetzt gerade von Hölzchen auf Stöckchen und ich fühlte, so würde das nicht funktionieren. Das Problem, das wir gerade haben, und darauf möchte ich jetzt mal zurückführen, sind Smartphone-Messengers. Das Problem, was ihr gesagt habt, ist, dass man die Verschlüsselung sozusagen, dass nicht richtig nachweisbar ist, ob diese Verschlüsselung wirklich nur zwischen Sender und Empfänger funktioniert. Weil zwei Punkte. Einerseits ist die Software nicht open source, das heißt, niemand kann genau wissen, was die da machen. Andererseits muss ich mich bei dem Austausch der Informationen, wie verschlüsselt wird, darauf verlassen, dass der Anbieter, der die Infrastruktur betreibt, nicht sagt, ich machs wie bei dir E-Mail, du schickst mir eine verschlüsselte Nachricht, ich mach die auf, verschlüssel die nochmal, schick die dann an deinen Kumpel. Das heißt, wir haben bei all diesen Smartphone-Messengern das Problem, dass es ein bisschen besser ist, als gar nichts zu verschlüsseln. Also quasi wie bei Skype, quasi wie bei HTTPS Everywhere. Ich muss mich darauf verlassen, dass der Anbieter vertrauenswürdig ist. Gegenüber vierten heißt es ja also, ich hab mich den Empfänger und als dritte Partei noch den Anbieter. Aber gegenüber vierten ist es sicher möglicherweise.
Sicher genug.
Solange, bis es sich mal jemand nachweist oder sagt, es ist erst mal sicher genug.
Es gibt auch mal so die Rahmenbedingungen. Auf einem Mobiltelefon hast du einfach andere Rahmenbedingungen als auf anderen Geräten. Da man sich da eh grundsätzlich darauf verlassen muss, dass da bestimmte Dinge nicht komprometiert sind, die man nicht nachprüfen kann. Also du kannst ein Mobiltelefon nicht ansehen, ob da jetzt, also es gibt gar keine Mittel zu sehen, ob man dem Gerät überhaupt noch vertrauen kann oder ob da Dinge drauf sind, die die Integrität des Geräts komprometieren.
Du willst sagen, dass da wieder Trojaner drauf sind, die die Informationen auch so ausleiten.
Ja, aber das weiß ich ja beim Rechner auch nicht. Also sagen, dass jetzt noch mal zusätzlich Fass aufzumachen, sprengt glaube ich den Rahmen des normalen Users.
Ja, noch mal eine Ecke einfacher als bei einem Mobiltelefon.
So, aber lass uns mal irgendwie einfach jetzt weiter bei den, also der CTC empfiehlt halt generell keine Produkte. Wir sagen, worauf man gucken sollte, wenn man dieses Produkt benutzen möchte, was die Kriterien sind, die wir persönlich dafür anlegen und diese Messenger erfüllen diese Kriterien gerade nicht. Aber man kann sagen, wenn man sie benutzt, dann macht man es schon mal ein bisschen sicherer als vorher. Und viele von den Ansätzen sind zumindest dazu geeignet, dass es auch wirklich passiert. Also sie sind schick und benutzbar genug, als dass sie...
Elternkompatibel.
Elternkompatibel besser als, oder schicker als WhatsApp. Und dann am Ende wird zumindest ein Schlüssel ausgetauscht und für 99% der Fälle ist es dann auch gut genug. Man muss aber auch wissen, dass es die 100%ige Sicherheit natürlich da nicht gibt an der Stelle.
Aber, und das nehme ich mit zu sagen, also ich finde einen der Vorteile bei diesen ganzen Angeboten ist ja, dass Sicherheit überhaupt zum Konzept einer Kommunikationssoftware gehört. Das ist ja nicht selbstverständlich sozusagen. Und die Leute haben zumindest sich Gedanken drum gemacht. Und das andere halt, wie gesagt, besser als nicht. Und es ist tatsächlich Elternkompatibel. So, jetzt haben wir noch einen Punkt auf der Elternliste, der steht nicht Google nehmen.
Man kann ja seinen Eltern in den Browser eine andere Suchmaschine einstellen. Also mir persönlich ist wichtig, dass wenn man seine private Kommunikation vor den Augen ausländischer Geheimdienste verbergen möchte, dann kann man natürlich auch wieder bei einer US-amerikanischen Firma vorbeigehen und ihr direkt das halbe Leben in der Form seiner Suchanfragen an diese Suchmaschine präsentieren. Und man kann sich natürlich auch dann mal bewusst machen, dass was dort dann an Informationen zusammengesammelt wird, auch ziemlich viel über dich und dein Leben und auch das Leben deiner Eltern aussagt, sodass sich vorher Gedanken zu machen, welche Suchmaschine man benutzt und welche Suchmaschine man seine Eltern benutzen lassen möchte und ihnen das einzustellen, das ist einfach nur ein Klick in den Einstellungen bei den meisten Browsern, benutzen sie eine andere Suchmaschine, lass es Daktaco sein, lass es Bing sein. Was ist natürlich...
Bing?
Wait, die Microsoft-Suchmaschine?
Ja, ich würde die nicht empfehlen, aber man soll sich halt bewusst seine Entscheidung treffen, welche von den Firmen man da sein innerstes dort in Form der Suchanfragen offenbaren möchte.
Okay, du hast ja jetzt gerade gesagt, der CCC empfiehlt keine Produkte. Darf ich dir vielleicht trotzdem die Frage stellen, welche Suchmaschine du persönlich benutzt?
Mehrere, also neben Daktaco, Google natürlich.
Aber sozusagen nicht nur eine, sondern du bist verschiedener. Welche hast du deinen Eltern eingestellt?
Meine Eltern benutzen Web.de eher als Suchmaschine.
Man kann es nicht immer ändern.
Meine riefen kürzlich an, dass ihr das Alter wisst, da ich nicht mehr ginge. Ich hab aber auch schon echt nichts mehr an dem Computer gemacht.
So, jetzt haben wir die Elternliste abgehakt. Aber wir haben jetzt eigentlich noch zwei Punkte, aber nur noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit. Das kann ja heiter werden.
Uff, na, ich find ja dieses PKI-Problem immer noch, also diese öffentliche Schlüsselinfrastruktur, was der alternative Ansatz ist, wenn du keine zentrale Instanz hast, die die Keys verteilt, dann brauchst du irgendeine Art von Vertrauen, wo du mal einen Anker brauchst, um dafür zu sorgen, dass du dir die Schlüssel deines Gegenübers besorgen kannst.
Okay, sagst du mir gerade, wir erklären gleich E-Mail-Verschlüsselung?
Wir erklären gleich Verschlüsselung, die gerade größtenteils für E-Mails benutzt wird, aber auch in anderen Chat-Klines zum Beispiel auch mit benutzt wird.
Machen wir gleich. Vorher Fritz Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr.
Und nun zu einer genialen Band, die aus Frankreich kommt, aber auf Englisch singt, ein knappes sachliches Statement von unserem Fritz Franzosen. Donnerstag, 21. November. Phoenix live in der Kolumbiale. Mit neuem Sound und neuem Halbblut.
Präsentiert von Fritz.
Nachricht mit Golo Schmid.
Auch nach der heutigen Sitzung des Parlamentarischen Kontrollgremiums sieht die Opposition in der Ausspäher-Affäre weiter Aufklärungsbedarf. Nach der dreistündigen Sitzung sagte der Ausschussvorsitzende und SPD-Politiker Oppermann, es sei immer noch nicht klar, wann und was die Bundesregierung über die Überwachungsaktion des US-Geheimdienstes NSA gewusst habe. Kanzleramtschef Pofalla wies den Vorwurf zurück, deutsche Bürger seien umfangreich durch den amerikanischen Geheimdienst ausgespäht worden. Der Datenschutz in Deutschland sei eingehalten worden, sagte Pofalla. Laut Oppermann will das Gremium nun im August zu zwei weiteren Sitzungen zusammenkommen. Das schwere Zugunglück in Spanien ist offenbar durch eine überhöhte Geschwindigkeit des Zuges verursacht worden. Der Lokführer soll Medienberichten zufolge eingeräumt haben, dass er mit 190 kmh unterwegs war, als der Schnellzug in der Nähe von Santiago de Compostela entgleiste. Zulässig war dort nur Tempo 80. Nach Angaben der staatlichen Bahngesellschaft gab es an dem Zug auch kein technisches Problem. Mindestens 80 Menschen kamen bei dem Umfall ums Leben, mindestens 180 wurden verletzt. Ministerpräsident Rajoy ordnete drei Tage Staatstrauer an. Ein dreitägiger Streik der Schleusenwärter hat den Schiffsverkehr auf der Spree in Berlin weitgehend lahmgelegt. Lediglich Ausflugsdampfer können noch auf dem kurzen Flussabschnitt zwischen Mühlendammschleuse in Berlin-Mitte und der Schleuse Charlottenburg pendeln. Die besonders bei Touristen beliebten Stadtrundfahrten wurden ganz eingestellt. Die Berliner Reederei befürchtet Umsatzeinbußen von etwa 30.000 Euro pro Tag. Auch in Brandenburg ist der Schiffsverkehr erheblich beeinträchtigt. Deutschland trifft im Finale der Frauenfußball-EM auf Norwegen. Im zweiten Halbfinalspiel gewann Norwegen gegen Dänemark mit 4 zu 2 nach Elfmeterschießen. Die aktuellen Temperaturen Berlin-Marzahn 20 zählen dort auf 24 Grad. Prenzlau 20, Ludwigsfelde, Prenzlau und Küritz jeweils 21 Grad. In der Nacht bleibt es meist trocken. Die Temperaturen gehen auf 18 bis 14 Grad runter. Morgen ist es dann überwiegend trocken bei Höchstwerten von knapp über 30 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin A111 Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Schulzendorfer Straße und Weidmannsluster Damm-Hermsdorfer Damm ist die rechte Spur gesperrt. Und A115A, wo es Richtung Berlin am Dreieckfunkturm ist, ist die Tangente in Richtung A100 bis 5 Uhr gesperrt. Zum Verkehr in Brandenburg A2 Magdeburg Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Wollin und Brandenburg an der Havel gibt es Behinderungen durch einen kaputten Laster. A10 südlicher Berliner Ring zwischen Genshagen und Rangsdorf blockiert ein kaputtes Auto die rechte Spur in Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz. Und A113 Zubringer Schönefeld zwischen Dreieck-Weitersdorf und Schönefelder Kreuz sind in beiden Richtungen Tiere auf der Straße. Ansonsten rollt es euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de. Und das Auge hört mit, man.
Eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch hier im Chaos Radio eben, Blue Moon und wollen noch ein paar Dinge erklären, die man zur Verschlüsselung möglicherweise benutzen kann. Wir haben jetzt ganz schön viel Zeit damit verbracht zu erklären, was man seinen Eltern beibringen kann als Verschlüsselung zu nutzen. Und da ging es um darum verschüsselte Webbrowsing, um Smartphone Messenger und um Festplattenverschlüsselung und darum, warum Skype eigentlich gar nicht so geil ist, aber manchmal besser als nichts. So, zu Gast sind immer noch Erdgeisten, Nibler und Linus. Und wir wollen jetzt nochmal, oder ihr wollt nochmal erklären, wie das ist mit diesem ganzen Verschlüsselungsding, dass man unter PGPG, asymmetrische Verschlüsselung, E-Mail Verschlüsselung und etc.
PGP ist ein standardisiertes Protokoll, was sich Phil Zimmerman vor so 15 Jahren ausgedacht hat, in dem es darum geht, verschlüsselte Nachrichten in einem standardisierten Format auszutauschen. Er hat dabei gleich noch eine Infrastruktur erfunden, in der man seine öffentlichen Schlüssel der Welt verteilen kann. Da ist jetzt spannend zu wissen, dass für diese PGP-Verschlüsselung, während man sich seinen eigenen Schlüssel ausdenkt, denkt man sich in Wirklichkeit zwei Schlüssel aus. Das eine ist ein Geheimerschlüssel, den behält man für sich, und ein öffentlicher Schlüssel, den hängt man überall hin und verteilt. Und da gibt es Betreiber von Servern weltweit, die sich auf die Fahnen geschrieben haben, dafür zu sorgen, dass diese Schlüssel überall von allen runtergeladen werden können. Und dass man, wenn man nach einer E-Mail-Adresse sucht zum Beispiel, diesen Schlüssel dann wieder findet und sich runterladen und dann innerhalb von PGP benutzen kann. PGP selber wird aktuell größtenteils für die Verschlüsselung von E-Mails benutzt, aber ist generell nicht darauf limitiert. Kann zur Verschlüsselung von Dateien auf deinem Computer benutzt werden, kann zum Verschlüsseln von Chatnachrichten benutzt werden.
Du kannst natürlich auch Podcasts.
Man kann damit auch Postkarten verschlüsseln. Die Idee dabei ist, dass, wenn du deinen öffentlichen Schlüssel jemandem zur Verfügung stellst, über irgendeine Art und Weise, dann kann der diesen Schlüssel mit deinem Schlüssel vergleichen, indem ihr ein kleines Exerpt damit... Na, da fällt eine Zahlenkolonie raus. Das sind so sechsten Hexadezimalzahlen. Und die kannst du vergleichen. Und das Tolle ist, wenn du diese Zahlen überprüft hast, dass die schon dieselben sind, wie was ich beim Erzeugen des Schlüssels auch als Fingerabdruck dort hab rausfallen sehen, dann ist man sich schon ziemlich sicher, dass du und ich jetzt denselben Schlüssel haben.
Also, ich lade mir aus dem Internet eine riesige Zahlenkolonne runter. Die heißt Public Keyblock. Und damit kann ich zu der PGP-Software auf meinem Rechner gehen, diese große Zahlenkolonne reinwerfen und sagen, gib mir mal bitte den Fingerabdruck dieser großen Zahlenkolonne. Dann kommt diese sechstenstellige Zahl drauf. Dann ruf ich dich an und sage, du, ich habe im Internet einen öffentlichen Schlüssel gefunden und habe den bei mir bei PGP reingeworfen. Es hat gesagt, es sind diese sechsten Zahlen. Dann sagst du, stimmt.
Genau, dann musst du nur noch der Stimme am Telefon vertrauen. Wir sind gerade schon im Aluhut-Modus.
Warum braucht man da einen öffentlichen und privaten Schlüssel? Was machen diese beiden Schlüssel?
Das Verfahren beruht darauf, dass man eben nicht nur einen Schlüssel hat, mit dem man Dinge fernentschlüsselt, sondern dass das entkoppelt ist. Also dass man zwei Schlüssel hat. Dinge, die man mit dem einen Schlüssel verschlüsselt, kann man nur mit dem anderen Schlüssel entschlüsseln. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo du mit dem öffentlichen Schlüssel von mir etwas verschlüsselst, dann kann ich das nur noch mit meinem privaten Schlüssel entschlüsseln. Umgekehrt, wenn ich Dinge mit meinem privaten Schlüssel verschlüssel, dann kannst du die nur mit meinem öffentlichen Schlüssel entschlüsseln. Deswegen macht man das immer doppelt. Man verschlüsselt mit seinem privaten Schlüssel und mit dem öffentlichen Schlüssel der Person, mit dem man sprechen möchte. Dann braucht er nämlich zwei Dinge, seinen privaten Schlüssel, meinen öffentlichen Schlüssel. Mit meinem öffentlichen Schlüssel stellt er sicher, ja, das kommt wirklich von dem. Und mit dem privaten Schlüssel von sich selbst kann nur er diese Nachricht entschlüsseln.
Das klingt so einfach. Hat es jemand nicht verstanden? Hat es jemand nicht verstanden? Jetzt anrufen.
0331 70 97 110.
Weil ihr müsst wissen, asrimetische Verschlüsseln zu erklären, das ist so eine Sache, an der verzweifeln Leute, die das gerne machen. Es gibt ganz viele Analogien, die man benutzen kann. Wer war das von euch mit den Schnappschlossern? Ja, hier, mach mal.
Mach mal das Schnappschloss. Um es einfach zu erklären. Das große geistige Problem für alle, die das erste Mal PGP benutzen, ist, welchen Key gebe ich denn jetzt jemandem? Dann liegt da ein Private Key und ein Public Key. Man denkt sich, ich möchte doch private kommunizieren, also schicke ich den Private Key an meinen Freund. In dem Moment kann man dann dieses Key Pair wegwerfen und darf es nie wieder benutzen. Die Analogie, die ich immer zum Einstieg nehme, ist, der Public Key ist ein... Ein...
Schnappschloss?
Schnappschloss, so ein Bügel-Schloss. Und der Private Key ist der Schlüssel dazu. Und dieses Schnappschloss, das verteile ich an alle meine Freunde und gebe es ihnen und die haben es alle dabei. Und jeder kann es haben, es ist auch nicht geheim. Deswegen wird es ja auf öffentlichen Servern, liegt es ja zum Abruf für jedermann. Und der geheime Schlüssel, mit dem ich das dann entschlüsseln kann, den habe nur ich.
Also den Schlüssel, der in das Schnappschloss reinpasst.
Genau, so verrückt.
Das sind jetzt zwei verschiedene Arten. Und ich war gerade sehr fasziniert davon, dass für mich zumindest Nibblers Erklärung verständlicher war als die mit dem Schnappschloss. Das fand ich witzig, weil wir haben vorher gestritten, ob jetzt die abstrakte Erklärung... Na ja, schon, aber es hinkt natürlich. Klar, ich kann es mit dem Schnappschloss vorstellen, aber jetzt sich vorzustellen, an jeder Stadt in der Welt hängen 50.000 Schnappschlösser, die meinen Namen haben. Klar, es ist eine einfache Erklärung, aber egal.
Wenn ich es nicht mit der Erklärung hatte, wäre es ein kleines sachlichen Fehler. Eine gute Analogie ist wie ein diagonaler Frosch.
Äh, gut. Also wer es noch nicht verstanden hat, warum es dort zwei Schlüsselteile gibt, der kann jetzt bitte anrufen. 0371 77 97 10 0. Wir haben nur noch bis 12 Zeit, aber ich würde gerne sicherstellen, dass das diesmal funktioniert hat.
Soll ich die Antwort schon mal geben? Es gibt die zwei Schlüsselteile, weil wenn es keine zwei gäbe, dann wäre das einzige Geheimnis, was die beiden Parteien teilen, das Passwort. Und das kann ich ja nun mal nicht offen irgendwo hinschreiben.
Das stimmt.
Wir haben jetzt noch die Art und Weise, die Nibble erklärt hat, wie man da seinen geheimen Schlüssel benutzen kann, um etwas zu verschlüsseln, da fällt dann eine Signatur raus. Das heißt, du verschlüsselst damit Teile deiner Nachricht und die andere Seite kann dadurch ja überprüfen, ob du das wirklich mit deinem geheimen Schlüssel verschlüsselt hast. Und du kannst diese Eigenschaft jetzt auch noch benutzen, um an Schlüsselsignaturen heranzuhängen. Das heißt, du findest im Internet den Schlüssel von Markus Richter. Du lädst diesen Schlüssel runter und du sagst jetzt, ich hab das überprüft, ich hab den Fingerprint mit ihm am Telefon ausgetauscht, das ist der wirklich. Und ich hänge da mal, damit alle das überprüfen können, eine Signatur auch wieder ran und sage, das stimmt so, verschlüssel das mit meinem geheimen Schlüssel und lade das wieder hoch. Alle anderen, die meinen privaten Schlüssel haben, mein öffentlichen Schlüssel haben und dem schon vertrauen, können einfach nachgucken, na ja, ich kenn jetzt zwar den Erdgeist, aber den Markus seinen Schlüssel nicht. Und ich hab irgendwie den Erdgeist seinen Schlüssel überprüft, ob der übereinstimmt. Und der Erdgeist mit seinem öffentlichen Schlüssel hat jetzt für mich nachprüfbar auch die Signatur an den öffentlichen Schlüssel von Markus rangehängt. Und habe damit eine transitive Vertrauensbeziehung aufgebaut. Also ich muss einfach nur entlang der gesamten Kette eigentlich allen vertrauen. Aber wenn ich den vertraue, dann ist für mich die Wahrscheinlichkeit schon hoch genug.
Gegenfrage, und damit komm ich jetzt zum Anfang der Sendung. Das Schlimme an der Überwachung sind ja die Metadaten. Wenn jetzt alle Leute ihre Schlüssel untereinander unterschreiben, habe ich nicht dann sozusagen genauso die Abbildung eines sozialen Netzwerkes in diese Schlüsselinfrastruktur gegossen, die dann jeder nachvollziehen kann?
Das ist korrekt.
Dann würde ich ja lieber anrufen.
Das hat zwei Effekte. Der erste ist, dass einige bestimmte Schlüssel eben nicht auf Key Server werfen. Und den anderen Effekt, dass es so einen kleinen Kult natürlich gibt, von wem der eigene Key schon alles signiert ist. Und dass man sich dann natürlich auch freuen kann, wenn man eine Signatur von einer bestimmten Person hat und damit angeben kann.
Dafür wurden dann früher so Key Signing Parties organisiert, dass da einfach dann der Fakt, dass man durch Zufall bei dieser Key Signing Party dabei gewesen ist, ist halt nicht ganz so doll so schlimm wie...
Also quasi das Problem an diesem System ist eigentlich, dass die Leute dazu tendieren, nur die Schlüssel zu signieren, die von Leuten, die sie persönlich kennen.
Das Schlimme ist, dass Leute auch anfangen, auf einmal Schlüssel zu signieren von Leuten, die sie nicht kennen.
Das ist das Problem tatsächlich mit diesem Web of Trust, dass man halt nur bis zu einer bestimmten Tiefe in diesem Netz Leuten vertrauen kann. Ich vertraue es vielleicht Erdgeist und vielleicht dir, Markus, aber ich bin mir halt nicht hundertprozentig sicher, ob alle Leute, denen ihr so vertraut, ob die...
Okay, jetzt haben wir grob mal erklärt, was an diesem PKI, an dieser Public Key Infrastruktur, also dieser öffentlichen Schlüsselinfrastruktur das Problem ist. Aber dieses PGP ist jetzt auch alt und abgehangen genug, dass man es eigentlich empfehlen kann. Und wir würden jetzt auch das gerne empfehlen, zum Beispiel zum Verschlüsseln von E-Mails. Und da gibt es, wenn du jemanden hast, der ein Windows zum Beispiel installiert hat, gibt es prima fertige Installer, die heißen PGP for Win. Klickst da einmal drauf, bringt alles mit, was er braucht. PGP und ein Plug-in für Thunderbird. Es gibt sogar fertige, wie heißt das, Mobile Apps, ein fertiges Paket, was du auf deinem USB-Stick drauf tun kannst, wo schon Thunderbird mit diesem Enig-Mail und PGP fertiggebundelt ist, die Scripts alle richtig aufgesetzt sind, dass er die Schlüssel auch findet. Jetzt hab ich genau vergessen, wie der heißt, aber das werden wir dann in den Show-Notz eintragen. Und mit dem kannst du einfach, wenn deine Eltern schon Thunderbird zum E-Mail lesen benutzen, dann kannst du dieses Enig-Mail dort anmachen und kannst schon mal die Schlüssel einfach runterladen, überprüfen und danach einstellen, dass er eigentlich immer verschlüsseln soll und hast danach eigentlich schon Crypto in E-Mails bei den Eltern zumindest für dich angemacht.
aus Rheiningen-Dorf, der will PDP nochmal anders erklären. Hallo Stefan.
Hallo.
Schieß los.
Ja, also ich hab das so gedacht, ist es nicht so, dass wenn sozusagen, wir nehmen mal als Einschlüsse, wer einen Stift, also die Farbe des Stiftes, dem schreibe und das andere wäre das Papier, also die Farbe des Papiers sozusagen. Und dann wäre das ja so, dass man nicht nur an der, dass man nicht an der Schriftfarbe und an der Papierfarbe erkennen könnte. Und da hab ich es so verstanden, dass ich die Zettel verteile und ich von einem sozusagen die anderen Leute drauf verschreiben kann. Und wenn irgendjemand mit Rot schreibt zum Beispiel, weiß ich wer das ist. Und er schickt mir dann sozusagen ein Zettel mit meiner Farbe und seiner Stiftfarbe.
Stefan, nein. Also ganz ehrlich, nein. Ich weiß ja, warum es geht, aber ich habe selbst da nicht verstanden, wie du das meinst.
Ich verstehe, was du sagen möchtest, aber der Text ist ja immer noch, also den kann man ja trotzdem lesen.
Bei dir fehlt die Verschlüsselung. Aber es ist eine schöne Analogie.
Für was?
Aber eben halt nicht für PCP.
Ja, Stefan, sorry. Aber vielen Dank, dass du es versucht hast.
Was wir vielleicht auch ansprechen sollten, ist Instant Messaging. Kann man, wenn man Java nutzt, eine Verschlüsselungstechnologie nennen. Diese nennt sich OTR, also Off the Record Messaging. Das hat ein paar andere Eigenschaften. Nämlich, dass die Nachrichten, dass im Nachhinein der Schlüssel veröffentlicht wird. Sprich, man nicht mehr nachweisen kann, dass die Nachrichten wirklich von mir gekommen sind. Sie aber auch nicht aufmachen kann, weil der andere, wie läuft das?
Nee, die Idee dabei ist...
Riecht ihr euch gerade selber durcheinander?
Nein, die Idee bei OTR ist, dass man auf beiden Seiten denselben Schlüssel hat und dadurch nie nachweisen kann, dass es wirklich die andere Seite ist, die diese letzte Nachricht geschrieben hat. Man hätte es auch selber schreiben können. Du kannst, wenn du nämlich chatterst und benutzt PGP und signierst deine Nachricht, dann willst du es im Allgemeinen nicht. Wenn ich irgendwie betrunken in meinem Messenger irgendwas reintippe, dann will ich nicht, dass die Gegenseite eine Signatur von mir hat. Und OTR ist einfach nur, dass beide Seiten denselben Schlüssel haben und damit man nicht beweisen kann einem Dritten, dass die Gegenseite etwas geschrieben hat, aber selber nachvollziehen kann, dass dem so ist.
Das hört sich für mich schon sehr aluhutig an, würde ich sagen. Also OTR ist eine Möglichkeit, Chats zu verschlüsseln? Ist etablierter als PGP, was wir gerade erklärt haben, um Chats zu verschlüsseln?
50-50 denke ich mal gerade.
Wo gibt es das? Ich kenne es von OSC. Da gibt es Adium, so ein Instant-Messenger und der hat das sozusagen gleich mit eingebaut.
Wenn man Java, also XMPP, Protokoll verwendet, dann kann der Client das in der Regel selbst oder mit einem Plugin. Also in dem Moment, wo man Java benutzt, muss man einfach mal sich gucken, ob es da für den Client, den man verwendet, ein Plugin gibt und dann einfach benutzen. Das ist nämlich superdoll einfach, das zu verwenden. Man sagt einfach nur mach OTR an, dann sehen beide Seiten, OTR ist an. So und dann ist das schonmal verschlüsselt. Und dann kann man noch darüber hinaus den Fingerprint vergleichen, genauso wie bei BGP und für den, mit dem man sich da unterhält, den Fingerprint auf, habe ich verifiziert. Dann wird das grün und man weiß in Zukunft, dass dazu stimmt.
Ist das dann sozusagen etwas, was man auch seinen Eltern, wenn man es soweit verstanden hat, dass man selber durchsteigt, andunen könnte, und das ist dann besser als Skype?
Problemlos.
OTR ist dann wirklich garantiert Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt und auch BGP im Chatprogramm ist Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt, ist aber wieder, wenn man seinen Eltern installiert, dann fragen die, warum Video anrufe nicht funktionieren und Sprachanrufe da drüber nicht. Und dann muss man denen dann irgendwie Mumble installieren und dann...
Man kann auch über XMPP... Ich hab da kürzlich einen XMPP-Klient ausprobiert, der das tatsächlich konnte.
Okay, das ist dann aber schon für fortgeschritten.
Ja, das ist schon für fortgeschritten und ja, meistens geht's damit einher, dass man irgendwie auch noch ein anderes Programm installieren muss, was die dann benutzen, um zu chatten, indem man eigentlich nur selber erreichbar ist. Es ist schon echt schwierig, dann seinen Eltern das mal eben zu installieren.
So, jetzt haben wir sehr viel Zeit damit zugebracht, was ich auch gut fand. Ich will tatsächlich sagen, das wichtigste Thema heute ist tatsächlich auch das, was am einfachsten zu verwenden ist, das, was man schnell vielen Leuten zeigen kann. Ich hoffe, ihr habt so ein bisschen Spaß dran gefunden und möchtet es möglicherweise noch weiter reichen. Falls ihr auch zugehört habt und denkt so, ich hab mich nicht getraut anzurufen, aber ich hab's doch nicht so ganz verstanden, ist dieses Konzept der Cryptoparty, das gibt es tatsächlich und das ist tatsächlich extra dafür gemacht, dass man dahin kommt und fragen kann, wie funktioniert das. Also, könnt ihr gerne machen, Cryptoparty.in ist so eine zentrale Webseite, die sammelt das für alle Städte, wo man sowas machen kann. Ich möchte jetzt hier die letzten paar Minuten, also so fünf ungefähr, nochmal sozusagen für den Aluhut-Modus freigeben.
Na, wir haben erst mal noch entdeckt, dass es eigentlich noch eine viel, viel, viel einfachere Möglichkeit gibt, grundsätzlich Datenverkehr vor den Geheimdiensten zu verstecken, indem nämlich einfach die großen Anbieter von Telekommunikationsinfrastruktur, also die Leute, die da so das Rückgrat des Internets zur Verfügung stellen, die haben da ja auch eigentlich nur sehr rechenmächtige Computer, die über Kabel à la couleur miteinander verbunden sind. Und diese Kabel reichen manchmal von einem Rechenzentrum in der Stadt zum nächsten, manchmal reichen sie in eine ganz andere Stadt, manchmal reichen sie auf einen ganz anderen Kontinenten. Und die Kommunikation darüber ist unverschlüsselt. Das heißt, wenn man mal eine politische Forderung aufstellen sollte, die dazu führt, dass grundsätzlich aller Internetverkehr zwischen den Datenzentren von einem Internetanbieter verschlüsselt ist, dann wäre damit schon mal viel gewonnen. Dann könnten die Geheimdienste nämlich nicht dahergehen und einfach sich auf das Kabel setzen und gucken, was da so durchgeht, sondern müssten sich dann schon sehr intensiv an die ISPs und Anbieter wenden, um dort mal mitlesen zu dürfen.
Das heißt, es limitiert sozusagen den Zugriff in der Form, dass nur der Betreiber selbst und die Dienste in der Erosdiktion, in der der Betreiber zu Hause ist, darauf zugreifen können. Da spart man sich dann nicht, dass man verschlüsselt, aber man weiß ein bisschen mehr, wer da alles reingucken kann. Und das sind halt keine Dienste aus anderen Ländern, die dann sagen, wir haben da mal alle Daten. Dann sagt der BND, das ist toll, dass ihr die habt, die hätten wir dann auch. Sondern das trennt das Ganze halt ein bisschen auf. Aber man kann nicht ein Land einmal alles abschneuchen.
Aber die kooperieren doch ohnehin zusammen. Ich halte das auf dem Layer nicht für adäquat. Da sehe ich jetzt echt wenig Gewinn, wenn man das machen würde. Ja, das ist eine politische Frage. Aber die politische Entscheidung ist inzwischen so weit, dass sie aktiv gezielt kooperieren. Und wenn man jetzt sagt, okay...
Man kann nicht den Menschen erzählen, sie sollen mal alle schön verschlüsseln. Während die Leute, die dort an den zentralen Knotenpunkten sitzen, wenn die da nicht mal ihre Daten verschlüsseln, dann ist das ein hohles Argument. Also sollen die mit gutem Beispiel vorangehen dafür sorgen, dass man nicht einfach nur auf dem Kabel sitzen muss. Dann grüßen sie halt nicht nur unsere Geheimdienste, sondern auch die, was ist der Standardbeispiel, Chinesen, Iraner, Israelis, die dann gerade mal nicht Freund des Tages sind. Die sollen natürlich auch nicht mitlesen können, wenn man jetzt mal gerade die US-Amerikaner an der Stelle lieb hat.
Also mit der Forderung, dass sie ihre dicken Internetdaten verschlüsseln, ist nicht die Hoffnung, dass das dann tatsächlich nicht abgegriffen werden kann. Aber es macht es dann einfacher, Verantwortlichkeiten aufzuzeigen, wenn so eine Daten mal wieder großflächig irgendwo auftauchen. Wir haben noch einen Anrufer, Lorenz aus Greifswald, der etwas von euch wissen will. Hallo Lorenz.
Mich würde eigentlich interessieren, ob sich da jetzt innerhalb des CCC so ein bisschen die Einstellung ändert. Also dieses so ein bisschen Gebetsmühlenartiges seit 20 Jahren wiederholte. Ja, wir müssen unsere Kommunikation verschlüsseln. Und ich mach das jetzt zum Beispiel auch bei E-Mails gelegentlich, wenn ich entsprechende Kontakte habe. Aber ich meine, es ist ja so, dass die Metadaten ja eigentlich viel interessanter sind. Das ist ja jetzt auch teilweise schon angeklungen. Das ist ja auch nichts Neues.
Das ist ja auch keine neue Erkenntnis.
Und die sind anders interessant. Also natürlich sind auch die Inhaltsdaten immer noch sehr spannender.
Ich glaube, Lorenz hat dir die Frage noch nicht gestellt.
Ja genau, ich möchte jetzt mal wissen, ist es so, dass wir in Zukunft erleben werden, dass der TTC anders lautende Empfehlungen ausgibt als, ja, verschlüsselt bitte was das Zeug hält, sondern eher so in die Richtung überlegt, dass ihr genau, ob ihr überhaupt verschlüsselt.
Oh Gott, das ist das, was du aus der Sendung gerade rausgezogen hast. Nein, eigentlich haben wir gesagt, dass wir gerade versuchen wollten, verschlüsselt selber, was das Zeug hält, aber geht noch daher und sorgt dafür, dass eure Eltern auch verschlüsseln. Und das hier sind gerade die Werkzeuge, die die niedrigst hängenden Früchte sind zum Pflücken, die man als allererstes da mal anschalten soll. Natürlich, alle Leute, die die technische Fähigkeit dazu haben, sollten weiter sämtliche harte Crypto, deren sie herbehaft werden können, benutzen, um ihre Kommunikation zu sichern. Und sollten auch noch dabei aufpassen, dass ihre Metadaten dabei nicht in fremde Hände fallen, indem sie zum Beispiel Toa benutzen.
Also wenn ich das noch mal als Übersetzer versuchen kann, ist es möglicherweise eine Änderung eingetreten, aber eher in der Richtung, dass man annimmt, wir können nicht alle sofort auf den höchsten Bestenstand der Crypto bringen. Deswegen können wir auch mal die Sachen vorstellen, die einfach zu machen sind und die sagen, zwar nicht perfekt, aber ein Schritt auf dem Weg sind. Hilft dir das was, Lorenz?
So, jetzt die Aluhut-Lösung.
Noch eine Minute Aluhut.
Eine Minute Aluhut? Ich hab ja öfter mal, eins meiner Hobbys ist ja Blogger aus dem grad demokratisch bedrohten Freundesland der Welt, sei es irgendwie die arabische Welt oder sei es das Baltikum, denen ich Dinge erzähle, wie sie ihre Rechner schützen können, wie sie ihre Kommunikation schützen können. Und dem hab ich auch erzählt, hier so nimmst du TrueCrypt und hab ihnen besondere Vorschläge gemacht, wie sie dann bei der Passworteingabe aufpassen sollen, dass es inzwischen irgendwie Abstrahlung der Tastatur kann man aufnehmen und man kann mit Teleobjektiven dabei zugucken, wie man das Passwort eingibt. Und so ein ägyptischer Blogger hat mich mit großen Augen angeguckt und gemeint, wenn mein Geheimdienst wissen möchte, was mein Passwort ist, dann bricht er mir die Knie, bis ich es ihm sage. Dann ist der Schutz des Passworts dort eher so sekundär. Und dann hab ich drauf gekommen, aber True Crypt kann auch Hidden Partitions. Du kannst also dafür sorgen, dass dort mit unterschiedlichen Passwörtern einfach unterschiedliche Dinge zu sehen sind. Du kannst dir also eine Partition anlegen, wo deine Familienfotos dabei sind, schön noch Gedichte, die du geschrieben hast und deine politische Arbeit einfach nur zu sehen ist, wenn du eine andere Passphrase eingibst. Was also bedeutet, dass du deine Festplattenverschlüsselung so gestalten kannst, dass man am Ende, wenn man dich zwingt, dein Passwort rauszugeben, kannst du ihnen eins geben, kommt sogar was raus, ist aber nicht das, was sie unbedingt sehen wollen.
Versteckt man dann in dieser Fake-Partition, wo man sich mit seinem Fake-Login anmeldet, dann auch so ein bisschen Porn, damit es glaubwürdig wirkt?
Na, was immer deine Festplatte hergibt, ist doch schon mal ein schönes Maß, was nicht auffällig ist.
Okay, gibt es jetzt also nur so Schlagwort-mäßig, gibt es irgendwie noch so eine Sache, wo ihr sagt, so hier, wenn ihr es nochmal wirklich hart wissen wollt, probiert das mal aus? Na ja, also so dieses Aluhut-Ding.
Ja, VPNs größten Platz. Es gibt inzwischen Anbieter, die für 5 Euro im Monat, die erlauben, nicht aus Deutschland mit deiner Internetverbindung zu kommen. Die hatten ja jetzt auch gerade akut auch Probleme. So eine schwedische Firma, die vorher mit The Pirate Bay viel zu tun hatten, weil PayPal und die großen Kreditkartenbetreiber ihnen den Geldhahn abgedreht haben und sie den Service da jetzt nicht weiter finanzieren lassen können.
Also VPNs sind diese, wo man seine Internetverbindung verbirgt quasi.
Das ist halt ein virtuelles privates Netzwerk. Das heißt, da kommt dein Internettraffic plötzlich nicht mehr aus Deutschland von der Telekom, bei dir zu Hause eine DSL-Leitung, sondern aus einem Rechenzentrum in Schweden, die für dich stellvertretend die Pakete ins Internet weiterreichen, was auch ganz praktisch beim YouTube gucken ist, weil du plötzlich nicht mehr die Gamerfresse gucken musst, sondern Musik hören kannst.
Ja, und insbesondere sieht dein eigener Internet-Service-Provider auch nicht, was du machst. So, Linus, bist du noch da? Ja. Ich wollte mich von dir verabschieden. Vielen Dank. Nibbler, auch vielen Dank. Und Erdgeist.
Darf ich noch bleiben?
Na gut. Musst du mit Henrik Schröder absprechen, der hier gleich den Night Flight macht mit Punk-Musik. Das war's für heute. Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß. Ich hoffe, ihr habt ein bisschen etwas mitnehmen können. Es wird noch Show Notes geben, wo ihr die Links klicken könnt. Den Podcast zur Sendung gibt es auf fritz.de, später dann auch auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Mein Name ist Markus Richter. Mir bleibt nur noch eine Sache zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.